I'm told that you just shot a movie with
one of the funniest people of all time
mr. wolf Ferrell is that yeah movie
together yeah I was so excited cuz Will
Ferrell is like one of my all-time
heroes I'll be him and me and they'll be
it that's it but he we were doing a
scene this was the more one of the more
surreal moments of my whole life which
is that we were doing a scene in the
morning-room
but we're shooting in the morning but it
was supposed to be a night and we're
supposed to be going to this nightclub
and we're supposed to have a lot of
energy and we're kind of sleepy and on
on Silicon Valley
Thomas Middleditch and I talked about
MPR a lot because we both love NPR and
we're always going through all the
different hosts and stuff so right
before we did the scene to get ourselves
pumped up somehow we'll and I ended up
talking about NPR yeah and there's a
there's a host on NPR named black Shmi
sing oh yeah glad you said oh yeah so we
started chanting right before they go
rolling speed and we go watch me sing
and I was thinking like Laxmi Singh is
asleep somewhere he has no idea Will
Ferrell is using her as his like eye of
the tiger yeah also she famously I don't
see Vikings going you think of like a
thousand Vikings I watch me swim with
her toe Perry sing is yeah was is my
cocaine where did you where did you
shoot this in Austria in Austria and and
who how did you find the people of
Austria with a nice were they live I'd
never been to before very nice people
but there was one guy who was so sweet
he was a whitewater rafting instructor
and he was also a driver on the
production so nice answered all her
questions very sweet but at one point he
said to one of the other actors he was
like it's so crazy like 60 years ago we
were fighting over like pretty much
nothing
and now verb like friends as countries
like there was this whole war and what
was it even about
[Music]
and I was like ah well better like it
was a misunderstanding
you tried to wipe out my whole blood
sort of a tomato tomahto never heard
anyone talk about world war 2 that was
incredible just things cop out too bad
[Applause]
like I was like you were in the mood to
not have genocide we took Poland there's
such a crazy conversation